thanks radio for telling us about the
importance of proper dessert selection
so let's choose our desserts now the
earliest platform version that our Apple
support is gingerbread at the current
time choosing Gingerbread means we can
cover over 99% of the devices active on
google playstore it's also the cutoff
for using Google Play services for
things like maps and location and the
Android support library the support
library package offers an implementation
of UI features that were added in later
releases of Android but now can be used
on older versions of the platform so
it's really useful
notice that we picked the latest version
of Gingerbread with API level 10 because
it contains additional bug fixes at API
level 9 doesn't have then we didn't go
ahead and click Next
we're going to choose the template blank
activity with fragment for background
contacts and activity serves as the
presentation layer for our UI and the
fragment represents a behavior or
portion of the screen
you
and now we have an option to modify the
names of the files that will be
auto-generated from the wizard the name
of our activity is mainactivity and the
layout will come from activity
underscore main which is an XML file in
a similar fashion the fragment sale will
come from fragment underscore main which
is also an XML file I'm going to do a
small change for the name of the menu
file to be called main dot XML because
on an older version of Android studio
that was the default name then we go
ahead and hit finish and now you should
have a newly created sunshine app with
the files on the left here by default
you may see the Android view of the
files which is a flattened version of
the project structure and it highlights
the key Android source files that you'll
need to edit in this course though we're
going to be using the project view
because that's what we had on the older
version of Android studio you can choose
any view that you prefer though make
sure you wait for the Gradle bill to
finish if you have any errors you can
check the guide in instructor notes
below as a tip you can check the build
up Gradle file which is located under
the app folder you want to make sure
that the compiled SDK version and the
target SDK version are both pointing at
the latest stable version of the
platform in this case it's 21 for the
Android 5.0 lollipop release once it's
done building we can add a custom app
icon that's more fitting for our weather
app right-click on the app folder and
click new image asset you can choose
from any of the clip art options or you
can use the one that we provide in the
download below then use a placeholder
icon we provide in a download below now
this will show up in the all apps screen
so that clicking on this app icon will
launch our app it will also show up in
the overview space if sunshine is one of
your most recent tasks the other lace
you might see this app icon is in the
action bar of our app in certain videos
of this course that were filmed earlier
on KitKat by default the action bar
shows the app icon with material design
on lollipop and later the app icon
doesn't show up by default anymore so
don't worry if you don't see it it's
fine and we're going to be styling the
action bar later in less than 5 anyways